aspective has developed an
nnp technology that combines both
linguistic and statistical approaches
for deep language understanding
analyzing product related information
such as reviews customer feedback and
product descriptions
to generate recommendations for any user
need for any type of product or category
for example aspectiva
provides recommendations on best
products for picnics best laptops for
travels
best trawlers for beach walking and any
kind of product recommendations that you
can think about
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
this is a classic story of israel's
startup nation meet ezra daya the
founder and ceo of aspectiva
ezra is the co-founder and ceo of
aspectiva a startup company acquired by
walmart in 2019 to establish its first r
d and innovation center in israel
ezra is an entrepreneur at heart
constantly striving to connect the dots
between technology and business with a
spatial focus on ai for e-commerce and
consumer applications
prior to founding aspectiva ezra managed
the text analytics group at nice systems
he holds an msc in computer science and
is the owner of publications and patents
in the field of natural language
processing
ezra welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you so much for joining me from the
aspective offices right
right aspect eva walmart offices in
israel aspectiva walmart offices uh
such a unique story it's such a proud
story in the israel ecosystem but but
again a fascinating one for me you know
as a you know as an nlp enthusiast as an
academic enthusiast you know i just love
when people take deep technology and
really interesting problems in their
life combine the two to find the synergy
opening up the first walmart offices in
israel and and and you know doing some
really really cool things but before we
talk about that i have to ask how does
it how do you and your wife speak five
languages to your kids uh how does that
work
yeah so
my wife actually immigrated from denmark
to israel
so she speaks uh
obviously hebrew english danish and
french her mother is
french wow
and myself i speak uh
english hebrew and arabic as a native
language
so both we have five languages that we
speak at home with the kids yeah yeah
it's fun how do you know which one to
which one to talk at which point in time
uh
it depends it depends when we don't want
the kids to
to understand us so english
doesn't work anymore so
french
with my lousy french
uh
but we get along
and when i
mad at the kids so arabic probably is
the
proper language
i love it incredible ezra take me back i
want you to take me back to 2013.
you're sitting with your co-founder ayal
you have a problem paint me the picture
yeah
so uh
absolutely
so um
i started
first of all maybe just to give you some
you know very uh
initial background about how did i you
know
find myself in the nlp area so
i started my career as an nlp researcher
and worked in several companies
and
in my last role before family aspectiva
i led the nlp group in my systems for
several years and the young was
a team member in my team
so
since ever i was fascinated about the
wealth of information over the web
about anything and everything
i always looked for
more and more information about things i
was interested in and of course
before making any purchase
so the thing is that i had to work very
hard to find answers to simple questions
like
which out of the book or which coffee
machine is the best for
my taste
so while i
used my nlp skills
and my team skills to solve business
problems for companies i worked for
i thought hey
it's about time to use my knowledge and
experience to
develop advanced nlp capabilities
for end users this time
helping them
make buying decisions by analyzing what
people think about any product or
service
so i decided to live nice and i offered
dail to join me in this journey
and we both started the new exciting
journey that's how aspectiva started
what was if you had to distill the
thesis that you had when you started
aspectiva with your background in yahoo
and nice and niels background and the
problem that you're facing
what was the thesis that the two of you
agreed on which triggered
your ability to to go and start on this
journey together
so on one hand the solution had to be
automatic by all means it means it
should work automatically for any type
of product or category without any human
intervention
otherwise it's not scalable it just
won't work an ecommerce website that
sells everything like walmart right
uh on the other hand it should be
super super precise meaning that if your
uh if the target audience is a simple
user you can make mistakes
no the target is not analysts in a
company that can
you know
somehow deal with
machine
outputs but when it comes to the a
simple user online you can't screw up it
shouldn't work so on one hand it should
be
fully automatic and on the other hand it
should be precise
so we thought that we can make it and
that's how we you know we got the
courage to go to this journey i love it
i so you're starting out
with you know with the al walk me
through some of the you know the
exciting moments of this journey and
later on i i have to understand what
it's like getting acquired by walmart
and and opening up the the walmart
office in israel
yeah so uh
you know
we started
first of all we had to raise funding
right but we had to work first on the
solution uh
but i was lucky enough to find very
quickly
uh the first 1 million dollars as a
seeds fund from angel investors in the
retail areas and
we started to you know hire people that
we worked with in the past in the nlp
area
and started to work on the solution
uh it was an amazing journey so uh you
know when talking about uh
excitement and challenges uh so first of
all fundraising and dealing with
investors
especially in the early stages is not a
big fun
right so it's uh
quite challenging especially when you're
used to dealing with nlp models
throughout the day and now you have to
to work with investors right it's a
little bit of a different experience
yeah yeah uh definitely
and i would say that the you know one of
the most exciting moments was going live
the first integration in a global
ecommerce website
and see how the solution we created
really works
that was amazing so you know you you
gave me the picture what was the
situation like where you huddled
together in a room separated your own
houses what was going on
yeah so
we know we worked very hard at the
integration
and uh you know
integrations doesn't work for the very
first shot and it's you know
from the beginning it's very frustrating
you think oh gosh the solution doesn't
really work that's it we're finished but
then you realize that the problem is not
with the algorithms it's not with the
nlp
it is with simple user experience issues
you couldn't think about
yeah and then when you do the you know
the needed adaptations and fixes we
went live in the first integration i
think it was in shop.com
global
on the us
website ecommerce website
and
you know it was amazing
receiving the first
the feedback from the
uh chief revenue officer
showing a clear impact on on the online
shoppers and clear increase in sales
and you start to see the traffic using
your
solution interaction with the aspect of
this widget in the website
and
you figure out hey it really works you
are making impact on the way people
make shop online
right and we help them to buy with
confidence now with this with our
solutions aspecting that solution
incredible
the the moment you understand
that the part of the
dissonance was the or the gap was a
consumer experience
how did that affect
or change the way that you're
approaching the future durations of your
product especially as you're approaching
this from a very
academic very deep technology mindset
and a deep expertise yet at the end
you're building a product that consumers
need to enjoy using it needs to provide
them with this delightful experience
right
yeah yeah absolutely so um
we started to build
several uis
for
for example we had a specific use case
user interface for hotels for booking
hotel bookings yeah it's a different
experience and we had a different one
for uh regular e-commerce
and for fashion we created a different
one
so that's how we started but still there
is the first phase in the integration
is fine tuning
you always need the first
stage of fine tuning and this is
something that you have to set
expectations with the customer that the
it's not going to work the first job you
have to do with the fine tunings until
you find the right
balance the
you know the the most uh
convenient way
for the uh online shoppers to consume
the data that according to the website
right now the next phase
beyond just understanding you know doing
doing doing an lp was the ability to
personalize the results and really
change retail right so if you're looking
at hotels and you're looking at
e-commerce that's great but what was
that shift to retail like with
respective that eventually led to this
great partnership with walmart
yeah so aspective has developed an
nlp technology that combines both
linguistic and statistical approaches
for deep language understanding
analyzing product related information
such as reviews customer feedback and
product descriptions to generate
recommendations for any user need for
any type of product or category uh for
example expectiva
uh provides recommendations on best
products for techniques best laptops for
travels
best trawlers for beach walking and any
kind of product recommendations that you
can think about
uh we also figure out that we can
generate
actually answers to complex questions
like what are the differences between
two given products now
why one product is better than the other
one
and so on so on many complex questions
about products that can be used for
example
in
devices like alexa for alexa shopping
and
uh before
being acquired by walmart we were in the
process with the in a plc with amazon
using our technology for alexa shopping
wow
yeah that that was uh you know uh
the first acquisition offer we received
was from amazon by the way
incredible
incredible as i take me to the day after
you're running a startup you're dealing
with investors you have employees you
have your burn rate you have your annual
run rate your i know revenue rate but
what happens the day after you get
acquired
you and they are what do you do how do
you you know what changes what stays the
same
yeah yeah everything actually everything
and everything is changed after the
acquisition
um
so first of all
you know uh
um
you had to
you know
there are very you know
tough things you have to make first of
all you have to terminate all this all
the agreements we had with customers so
before joining walmart we worked with
various companies in the us including
bedbath and beyond booking.com sony and
others it wasn't easy to terminate
the service of these companies
especially with sony by the way
they took it very hard
and yeah yeah that's a good sign
absolutely it is
and
um so as i mentioned uh before the
walmart acquisition we were ordering
acquisition process with amazon
and then walmart came into the picture
bidding against amazon for acquiring the
company so
it was really an amazing experience
having negotiations both with amazon and
walmart
was that was it fast was it slow
how
you know how does it feel to be in the
middle of all this
so with walmart it was very fast
we were you know we were about to close
the deal with amazon
wow and
yeah and and just before closing walmart
getting got into the picture
and we run into a very quick uh
due diligence process with with walmart
it was crazy it was really crazy a
process i didn't see my family didn't
see my kids
um
[Music]
but i think that
the moment that you know that
you realize hey this is the point we
you know we worked for very hard
is when you are
negotiating
the
the acquisition price
i must say this is
this is something that you know i didn't
you you couldn't believe that it's uh
this is the point when you agree on the
price
and from that point everything is very
easy
and
we are lucky to have uh two acquisition
offers in order to make
a bid between the two
and um
when it was clear that we are going with
walmart
and
uh it was for many reasons by the way
not just because of these size but also
the potential of using
uh
the system using using the nlp agency
that we developed
had a lot more potential in walmart
walmart is you know i'm sure that our
audience you know are familiar with
walmart but the numbers are
you know
astronomical
absolutely there are 2.5 million
employees in walmart
that is a number that i think very few
people including myself can fathom and i
have to share with you ezra before you
continue
i took a course
about a product and we were working
closely with an executive from target
about different technologies to
incorporate and target
a walmart competitor
and you know we were looking at nlp we
were looking at the different things and
i was constantly mind blown
at the size of these companies the
impact that they have i think with
walmart specifically there are stats
about the proximity of a walmart to
every american in the u.s the
the accessibility is ridiculous the way
that they're thinking about innovation
is incredible and we don't hear enough
about it in israel i have to say but but
it it's something that for me i got a
really big shock out of it so please go
on
yeah yeah i mean walmart is uh
you know it's a fortune one company
right it means that
it's it's a
you know it's a word of everything you
have everything in walmart
uh yeah as you mentioned
90 percent of the americans live
you know
like 10 miles
uh incredible
walmart stores so the distribution is
amazing
and uh
yeah yeah i mean there's a lot of
potential in walmart and we decided to
go with role models there were i i might
say that
the process was uh you know we felt at
home with one
right that's incredible visiting
bennettville was
very exciting
very amazing you know at walmart
headquarters i'm in benneville
we felt very convenient closing the deal
with walmart and
that's what we did and and you know i'm
glad that my investors also agreed that
um no walmart should be the one to
acquire aspectiva
and uh yeah so we found ourselves as the
first walmart acquisition in israel
first tech office of walmart and israel
this is very exciting i i love it how
did they how did your employees take it
you know your partners that worked very
hard
what was their reaction like internally
what was the vibe you know i there
wasn't slack back then but but what was
the vibe before what would be the vibe
on slack today
um wow i can't believe it
uh it's a dream that
comes true we worked very hard for six
seven years for to reach to this point
that that
that was the reaction of my
employees and
they were yeah it was astonishing
you know i
can also say that at the first day after
the uh acquisition was announced my all
my producers
got a mail from amazon they didn't know
that we're going to close with walmart
um offering them to
move to amazon it was
yeah yeah so at that point
yeah there was they really wanted uh
to
buy aspectiva and they were very they
were very disappointed that it didn't
work out so
it was you know at the same time i was
very happy to be part of walmart but
again i also got you know we developed
relationship with amazon team great team
and i wish we could be with both teams
right but it's not possible
um to be realistic
right 100
the journey is so so fascinating and
and i and i i personally i love it and i
you know i wish for myself one day to to
develop something that is meaningful
enough to to go to you know have the
success that
that spectiva had but because really i
mean what it sounds like is that you
have this you know this this background
you have this understanding of a
technology you have this pain point that
you realize you very accurately develop
a technology to solve that pain point
obviously that pain point is so big and
is so relevant in a timely manner that
there are various you know the biggest
companies in the world that are that are
posing a lot of interest in this and the
way that you're talking about the
humanity behind this acquisition and the
way that you are approaching it the way
that the other the bidders felt about it
i think that really shows a little about
who aspectiva is and the type of company
that you've built and they're very proud
you know
very proud story in the israel ecosystem
so thank you very very much and thank
you for the inspiration
and and just to continue doing amazing
things for our ecosystem and developing
great technologies thank you
thank you michael it was a pleasure